[Music]
so earlier in the month it was announced
that warner brothers would be shelving
their new batgirl film after having
already spent 90 million dollars to
produce it the move was devastating for
batgirl's fan but it made sense from a
financial perspective the studio
realized that the film would be a
massive embarrassing flop and decided
that they'd rather just take the tax
write off than cut their losses now of
course if they'd asked me
i could have told them before they even
made the movie that a movie called
batgirl would be terrible
i mean replacing batman with a 97 pound
female it's like remaking jaws
except with a with a dolphin
and on second thought that analogy
probably makes batgirl seem more
interesting than it really is
although we'll never know for sure as
the studio executives have taken the
batgirl film
and thrown it into a volcano ensuring
that nobody ever sees it and it never
falls into the wrong hands
but the untimely demise of batgirl has
created a void now the public is
clamoring for a new feminist superhero
to step in and carry the mantle
well really nobody is clamoring for a
feminist superhero literally nobody on
earth that's the whole reason why
batgirl ended up in the volcano to begin
with be that as it may hollywood is
ready to ready to deliver what nobody
actually asked for or wanted and this
week marvel's new series she-hulk
debuted on disney plus
even before the show premiered the cast
had already started using the batgirl
tragedy as a means of morally
blackmailing both the studio and the
public into supporting their project the
headline on yahoo news reads after
batgirl cancellation she-hulk cast and
creators stressed the importance of
studios supporting female-led superhero
projects
translation
you all better pretend to actually like
this bull we produced or you're all
sexist
the message is made clear in the article
says marvel boss kevin feige was among
the first to reach out to batgirl
directors adil l arby and baleel falah
who also worked on ms marvel to express
his support after the cancellation news
likewise the team behind she-hulk shared
their sympathy
quote it is so hard to imagine the
disappointment that those filmmakers
must be feeling because these projects
take years says she-hulk director and
executive producer cat quarrel
i've been working on this for years and
the idea of it never seeing the light of
day is well it must be crushing shield
has long been regarded as one of the
most powerful feminist icons found in
the pages of comic books making the
arrival of attorney at law all the more
impactful at this particular moment in
time
koiro says it's exciting because just
her very existence is a feminist she's
large she's in charge she controls her
own narrative the mcu has for a very
long time been very male heavy there
hasn't been a lot of female
representation
so it's nice to finally start making
some progress in that area
now i do agree that large
is quite often an apt description of
feminist i'm not sure about the rest of
it though in any case the blackmail
worked and she-hulk despite being just
as humiliatingly terrible as batgirl
would have been was allowed to debut and
be seen by literally dozens of people
one particular clip from the show's
premiere has been making the rounds
online though helped by the imdb db
twitter account which tweeted the video
with the caption ahem say it louder for
the people in the back
the clip shows she-hulk
lecturing regular hulk about how
difficult her life is
because of course the whole reason
audiences flock to superhero shows is to
hear their favorite superheroes complain
and feel sorry for themselves
here's the clip
here's the thing bruce i'm great at
controlling my anger i do it all the
time
when i'm catcalled in the street
when incompetent men explain my own area
of expertise to me i do it
pretty much every day because if i don't
i will get called
emotional or difficult or
might just literally get murdered so i'm
an expert at controlling my anger
because i do it infinitely more than you
as we can see self-pity is she-hulk's
superpower her high-pitched whining is
enough to make any super villain
flee out of just sheer annoyance
of course
the experiences she describes in that
monologue which was apparently curated
from a twitter thread written by a
jezebel blogger are all at worst
mild annoyances
i mean if those experiences are the
worst hardships in your life then you
have led an exceedingly privileged
existence
and trying to explain
why her life is so much harder than
bruce's she-hulk can only mention the
trauma of receiving unwanted compliments
and of having her credentials questioned
and she then says that she can't
complain about these experiences because
if she does she'll be insulted or
murdered
the interesting thing about this claim
is that it's it's not only delusional
and insane but also self-negating she
clearly has no problem complaining and
is quite eager to do so and far from
being killed for it she's instead hailed
as a hero
this is a common theme with the
feminists that they claim that they're
not able to talk about their troubles
when in fact that's the only thing they
ever talk about
and any time one of them does talk about
it the others say yeah finally someone
said it what i mean finally someone said
it this is all we've heard this a
billion times
but simply exaggerating your own
sufferings is one thing you know we can
all tend to fall into that trap
sometimes the real problem with
she-hulk's approach here and with the
approach of feminists in general is the
assumption that no man could ever suffer
or does ever suffer like women suffer
she-hulk declares her struggles to be
infinitely more numerous and severe than
bruce's or any other man's
now we could maybe ignore the claim if
it was just coming from a character
called she-hulk but the problem is that
this is the attitude that our society
seeks to foster in girls that's why they
put it in the monologue to begin with
in truth there is nothing to be gained
by comparing two groups against each
other and trying to determine who has a
harder time of it but if that is the
game we're playing
most of the statistical evidence would
seem to suggest that in modern america
women generally have the better deal
that's why girls are more likely to
graduate high school less likely to be
suspended or expelled women are less
likely to commit suicide to become drug
addicts to become hopeless to homeless
to
less likely to suffer from workplace
injuries women are less likely to be the
victims of violent crime they're less
likely to be blown to pieces on the
battlefield
but sure i guess the homeless
drug-addicted suicidal war-injured
veteran on the street
probably doesn't get cat-called very
often so he's got nothing on she-hulk
now nobody is suggesting that women have
no challenges or obstacles to overcome
but the idea that they have more
obstacles than men or more serious ones
is just not borne out by the facts i'm
sorry
and besides as already noted the
comparisons are absurd and pointless the
only thing worse than being self-pitying
is to be competitive in your self-pity
it's bad enough to walk around dwelling
on your misfortunes it's even worse to
insist that you win the prize for the
most misfortunate person in the world
and it's especially ridiculous to make
this claim when you are a young
attractive woman in the modern western
world
because our modern society is
essentially tailor-made to facilitate
the happiness and success of that
category of people
this has probably been a more serious
analysis of a she-hulk monologue than
was necessary but someone has to
mansplain these things to her and i was
more than happy to step up to the plate
and someone must especially say to
she-hulk
that you ma'am
are canceled
i know you're craving some more matt
wall show content well i have some great
news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com and subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast i'll see you there